اخفاقات عديده للقوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
رافقتها عقوبات وعزله دوليه من كل حد وصوب
لكن يبدو ان ادوات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين لم تنذ بعد تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه كشف ان بعض الدول
الاوروبيه اصبحت حذره من ان الكرملين قد
يستغل مجتمعاتها المفتوحه لتعميق محاولات
التجسس لايصال رسائل معينه او لمعرفه
المدى الذي يمكن ان تصل له الحرب في حال
تطور الصراع ليشمل دول الغربيه الدول
الاوروبيه بدورها باتت تنتج استراتيجيات
المختلفه لمواجهه روسيا فنلندا التي تمتلك
اطول حدود مع روسيا قررت منع دخول اي
مواطن روسي يحمل تاشيره سياحيه اما
النرويج فقد قررت رفع ميزانيه الدفاع ب
10% وتفكر في اعاده اي مواطن روسي الى
حدود بلاده في حين تعمل فرنسا بطرق مختلفه
لمواجه التجسس الروسي فهي تلجا حين لطرد
الجواسيس الى بلدهم وحين تعزلهم بصوره
سريه
معطيات عده ربما تدفع الكرمل للتباع النهج
نشر الجواسيس في اوروبا في ربما يرتكز بوت
على ما حدث في المانيا من محاوله انقلاب
وما اظهره الدوله من هشاشه امنيه كارضيه
لمخططاته المستقبليه بضرب اوروبا الى جانب
ما يدور في اروقه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من
انقسام في المواقف التي تظهرها غير موحده
اضافه الى قضايا الفساد التي خرجت الى
العالم في البرلمان الاوروبيه
تحدي سياسيا واستراتيجي وراء محاولات
التجسس للكرمله وبات التهديد الروسي يتخذ
اشكال متعدده عسكريا في اوكرانيا وامنيا
في اوروبا وفق اجهزه الاستخبارات الغربيه